So president Trump held a campaign rally in
Florida yesterday and he floated the idea
of creating his own propaganda news network.
Now, of course, we've all been watching the
Trump presidency unfold over the past three
years. Shouldn't be a terrible surprise to
us that he wants to do this. But I think still
anytime you have a president talking about
creating his own state run media agency, that
should give us a little bit of pause. Right?
So yesterday at the speech, Trump was talking
about his normal things, how the media is
just the worst. They're corrupt. They're the
enemy of the people. How CNN is especially
bad. And then he gives us this little gem.
CNN
is a voice that really seems to be the voice
out there and it's a terrible thing for our
country and we ought to start our own network
and put some real news out there
because they are so bad. They are so bad for
our country. They are so bad for our country.
I go out there and they say,
boy, the media hates your country. And it's
just a shame. It's just a shame. And we really
are. We are looking at that. We should do
something about it to put some really talented
people and get a real voice out there and
not a voice that's fake.
Yeah. And Trump also said that he would get
the best people to work in his administration
too. And we all know how that turned out,
not so well. Uh, I don't trust that he'd be
able to get the best people to work at as
news outlet either. Of course there's a serious
angle to all this. It's more a Trump giving
into his authoritarian tendencies. It's more
Trump attacking the press. It's not good that
Trump supporters just view the president as
the ultimate source of truth and knowledge.
Uh, we don't want to see that. We don't want
to see people just unequivocally buying into
whenever the government tells them. But I
also want to talk about how this is just this
sort of a logical progression of Trump's relationship
with the media. Because of course for the
longest time Trump's go to was Fox news, Fox
news and Trump were buddy buddy.
There were two peas in a pod that was true
for, uh, when Trump was running for president.
And it was true for the first two or so years
of Trump's administration. But then with signs
of an economic downturn on the horizon and,
uh, the Mueller report stuff coming out with
the Ukraine scandal, there started to be a
little bit of a divide, a Trump turning on
some of the Fox news hosts, Fox at times turning
on Trump. So we have one tweet here I want
to show you where Trump turns on Fox. He says,
I don't want to win for myself. I only want
to win for the people. The new Fox news is
letting millions of great people down. We
have to start looking for a new news outlet.
Fox isn't working for us anymore. Going onto
say watching fake news. CNN is better than
watching Shepard Smith, the lowest rated show
on Fox news.
Actually, whenever possible I turned to O
a N N so O a N N is one American news network.
It is a right wing outlet that's even more
favorable to Trump than even Fox news is a,
which is kind of hard to believe, but it's
true. And uh, yeah, I like why is Trump no
longer satisfied with OANN? Maybe they're
not big enough, maybe they're just not ready
for it or maybe he just doesn't want to go
through the heartbreak again because Trump
and Fox news for the longest time they were
buddy buddy. They were two peas in a pod and
then he had to go through that tumultuous
breakup with them. And I don't know if he
wants to go through that heartbreak again.
I don't know. I don't know if he wants to
trust another news organization again. I think
he just wants to take the power in his own
hands and be in control of the propaganda.
Could this be a, another Trump TV preview?
Like remember back in 2016 in the lead up
to the election, pretty much everyone thought
that Trump was going to lose and I think even
Trump himself thought he was going to lose.
So there are plans in the works to make a
Trump TV. Maybe Trump is planning for life
post presidency. Maybe he expects to lose
in 2020, or maybe he expects to be a impeached
and convicted by the Senate, kicked out of
office. I won't hold my breath over that stuff,
but I think it does stand to reason that he
wants to get his chips in order. So we have
some backup plans in case he does get kicked
out pretty soon. And let's remember too that
uh, Trump already has his own propaganda show.
It's called the real news update with Leora
Trump, Trump's daughter-in-law. And uh, it's
truly viral stuff. We talked about it a couple
of years ago when the show debuted, but not
sense. They're still making that show. They
are still making that show. I'm going to show
you a clip permit now,
despite attempts from the fake news, did you
rail the progress made at the summit? The
president was a statesman and bravely put
America first along with the first lady.
Yeah. So truly vile stuff here. Uh, but Hey,
if Trump wants to have more than just one
show, if he wants an entire network for himself,
maybe everyone in his family can have their
own show. So like Don jr can have a show and
Eric can have a show. May be Tiffany Trump
can have her own show. Uh, we'll, we'll see
how this all works out. I want to thank everyone
for tuning in. After the break, we're going
to David, uh, taking live calls and David
answering audience questions. It's stuff that
we had prepared from earlier in the week.
Uh, this is the last footage that you'll be
able to see if David right
with an appendix intact. So I hope you enjoy
the rest of the show today. Thanks for tuning
in